many children are already headed back to
school after their summer breaks but for
some there may not be enough teachers in
their classrooms one survey found that
72 percent of school districts
nationwide did not have enough
applicants to fill all of their open
teaching positions manuel bojorquez is
in miami with a look at the challenge
and some potential solutions manny good
morning
good morning to you when the school year
starts here on wednesday miami-dade
county public schools will join the
number of school districts across the
state opening with vacant teacher
positions get this across the state of
florida there is an estimated 8 000 open
teacher spots and florida is not alone
at a speedy to charter school system in
phoenix arizona finding enough teachers
for their 1 thousand students has been a
challenge says ceo armando ruiz right
now you can't hire enough teachers in
arizona you're going to have to go out
there and find teachers wherever they
are
wherever they are in whatever part of
the world that they may be and that's
exactly what they do hiring a third of
the charter systems teachers from abroad
the leaders control your dreams and
let's start reading like language arts
teacher sandra caicedo who is from
bogota colombia and you're enjoying it
yes do you think the students also are
getting something out of it i hope with
all my heart they have a lot of
curiosities about teachers that come
from other places still the need here
underscores a growing problem for the
nation's schools not enough teachers
nationally there are more than 280
thousand fewer public school teachers
than before the pandemic arizona has
more than 2 200 teacher vacancies in
illinois 88 percent of school districts
surveyed have a shortage florida has
about 8 000 empty spots the state's
governor recently put out a call to
military veterans to apply to teach our
veterans have a wealth of knowledge and
experience they can bring to bear in the
classroom a new state law allows those
who served for four years to fill k-12
teaching jobs even without a bachelor's
degree
but some see the nation's teacher
shortfall as less of a shortage and more
of a failure to improve salaries and
working conditions we put in an
expansion request jason hammond is
president of international alliance
group an organization that helps place
teachers from abroad in u.s schools
through a j-1 visa the pandemic has
exacerbated the current situation that
shortage there's many contributing
factors to that of course teachers
continue to be lower paid than other
professionals with the same amount of
education and responsibility levels and
while he believes the cultural exchange
is a benefit to schools that use it it's
not meant to be a remedy for the problem
altogether and the visas are only good
for three to five years oh i like that
which is why manolin narca a chemistry
teacher in osceola public schools in
florida is entering her final year here
before returning to the philippines i am
so thankful even if it's a short-term
stay but i'm so thankful to be exposed
to the broad american culture and
society and be able to bring with me my
own background from the country where i
came from it's been great
as if a teacher shortage were not enough
school districts are also struggling to
hire in other areas there is a severe
shortage of school bus drivers and as
many as 86 percent of schools across the
country are reporting a tough time
filling those open spots nate
that is one word i hope we get rid of
soon shortage i am tired of hearing it
manny thank you
especially for teachers it doesn't make
any sense that teachers don't get paid
the what the way they should right or
the job that they need and if anything
they're needed now more than ever before
rather than raise the salaries pay a
little bit more in taxes no one wants to
do it i don't want to do it either we're
now bringing people from overseas to
teach our kids and taking people from
the military to do it i mean that that
should be a big warning sign these are
the people that we lean on to mold our
young minds
and they are underpaid and overworked
every single year i wonder there's
getting worse yeah that's the truth all
right